hard to respect Christianity when
they're obviously selling out to agendas
yes I think which is why we need a 21st
century Crusade let's go Dave's vault
so guys if you are somebody who trains
like me when I'm doing boxing when I'm
joking when I'm doing bodybuilding this
can benefit you it's shinjit from
Nature's Blends as you guys know I get
my honey my black seed oil and many
other supplements from them it has 86
plus minerals including zinc magnesium
selenium fulvic acid and 59 fully lab
tested the highest in the market boost
testosterone levels Boost energy levels
and safe for men and women so check out
Nature's Blends in the description box
and enjoy it okay
to your brothers and sisters and dear
friends so we're going to react to this
video of these two chaps I don't have
you seen these guys before I have yeah
they keep popping up here and there so
let's watch it for yourself because this
guy on the left makes a comment let's
see why he wants to be on the far left
he's on the manhood of the oh yes okay
so there you go let's emotions
deeply religious I had no idea you said
you had no idea what I had no clue you
were so religious yeah bro yeah
Jesus is the real deal man are you uh
you know what you're you're close with
the Tates Chase is like on a crusade to
bring Andrew back to Christianity
Christianity yes oh instead of Islam
yeah that's what well that's what Chase
told me right yes yes I wanna I wanna
bring Tate to the truth man oh man
that's a conversation for you and Taylor
do you mind if I bring something up in
regards to you switching Tate over I
think your best bet is to start with
getting Christianity to actually stand
behind the religion yes these gay flags
in front of churches not that I'm
against gays but that's not with the
religion yep the things that the
Christianity is allowing is making
Christianity lose in a lot of ways to
Islam and I think that's the basis right
now for Christianity to return is to get
back to the backbone and the actual
religion and not being socially correct
with people you and I are a hundred
percent on the same page bro absolutely
one of the phenomenons I'm sorry I gotta
say this one of the phenomenons that is
driving so many people towards Islam
right now is Christianity kind of
again one week yeah dude bro you you
look you you go on Twitter they've got
trans people literally dancing inside of
churches across the West what is that
it's a huge departure from the word of
God and it's it's really fascinating to
watch too because so many young dudes
watch Tate and they look up to Tate and
they see Tate saying hey Islam is more
based than Christianity is and so
they're following Tate into Islam my
problem with it is because when you when
you object I believe when you
objectively pursue truth you end up at
Jesus and a lot of these people they're
looking at Islam not as what is the most
True Religion but what is the most based
religion I believe Christianity well
it's like what religion do they respect
the most and that's the problem it's
hard to respect Christianity when
they're obviously selling out to agendas
yes I think which is why we need the
21st century Crusade let's go with Deus
Vault okay so in a nutshell there's
something that he made which is a true
statement is that he says that people
are following Islam not because it's a
True Religion but because it's got you
know it's pragmatic it works and you
know because it's uh it has Traditional
Values Etc which is true and we say that
we actually say that statement is more
true on our side why because the point I
was trying to make is if I don't think
undertake him for that reason and even
if it did come for that reason you know
Allah we believe that God Almighty works
in mysterious ways the prophet Muhammad
peace to give so many gifts and camels
and wealth to the bedrooms to soften the
heart towards Islam this is from our our
religion do you get it the softness
somebody look we need to understand
something somebody can come to Islam not
because of dawah somebody can come to
Islam from crazy reasonable there was
one woman I heard she literally came to
Islam because Abdul Rahim green was
talking about istanja like cleaning
yourself in the toilet now you might be
thinking how does that what we're trying
to see is that people can come to Islam
for a variety of reasons but if anybody
our premise is not that Islam for
example is growing or it's because of
this because it's pragmatic and its
Traditional Values that's that's an
element to it but Islam is the truth
there's a distinction between the two
pragmatism will get you into Islam but
theology will keep you exactly and
that's what they they're saying okay
that's the reason Andrew uh came into
Islam but what's the reason that he
stayed in Islam and in order to do that
you need to look at his discussions and
he goes into depth he talks about the
theology he talks about
um the issues he had with Christianity
he talks about his issues with atheism
so this this assumption is is quite
flawed exactly because the thing is here
is that you need to understand let's say
it was Christianity that was very like
for example very Traditional Values they
were not selling out their religion and
having these individuals come and do all
kind of stuff in the church if I was out
know well there for Traditional Values
but the moment if I learn what the
doctrine of the Christianity is brought
I'm not staying in that diligent bro
when I was looking to to a religion the
moment I heard it just came to my ear
for a split second that they believed
that Jesus is good bro I can remember
that yes I used to read the Bible about
I used to read the Bible bro and Wale
the moment and I never saw this in the
Bible by the Jesus being Divine nowhere
until I came across Christian Muslim
debate the moment I heard a Christian
Pastor debate in ahmeda saying that he
is the Son of God or he is God I was
like bro you don't need to see anything
else to me
you've said enough done I'm trying to
say so this guy I think his name is
Chase yeah you need to understand
something my brother if you're just
watching this that you keep saying Jesus
is the truth and this Etc we as Muslims
to believe in Jesus we believe in this
Resurrection we honor his mother we've
all trapped off his mother so the thing
is here that you need to understand
millions of people and you've never seen
this in history bro there is no uh
historical analysis or anything for that
matter that millions of people leaving
Islam bro the past 10 yes 15 years
millions of Christians have left their
faith and thanks to atheists because
they were attacking religion as a whole
but now what they do is they did is they
took the Faith from the Christian
Christians and now Muslims have come and
given them the dawah so the point is
what Islam's belief system is what bro
we believe we're in five Gods one God
what do you mean by one word because the
Christians say they want so Chase is
going to ask you what's the difference
between your monotheism and our
monotheism because we believe in one but
it's going to come and say no we believe
God this one is also yeah but we believe
that there's none worthy of worship
besides God I.E there's no partners he
has no weaknesses your first page of the
Bible talks about God created the Earth
and or the world in Six Days on the
seventh day he took a rest we believe he
doesn't sleep he doesn't Slumber he
doesn't have a son he's not required to
send himself or his son to die for
everybody's sins for blood so that's
what we mean by monotheism that he's
independent from anyone and anything so
to say that oh no he's he needs to send
down his son or he has to come and offer
a blood sacrifice well he needs to do
this or do not needs or has no we we
believe
there is none like him
say he has got the one no mother no
father no son no daughter and he's not
requiring of anything that's the
difference exactly just to add on like
for example we have three aspects of
tohit
and this is what distinguished us from
you guys so people are watching this
number one we single out Allah into the
lordship so we don't come and say that
in the beginning Jesus Prophet Muhammad
was with Allah like they say for example
in the beginning that Jesus was with the
father but I thought he is the father
anyways so the point is we single out
Allah in his lordship meaning he is the
one who sustains provides for us and the
one who controls all effects without any
need of anybody then we single him out
in meaning that we single him out in
worship and this is where every single
other most religions fall into disbelief
and this is why we say we have pure
monotheism because when we ask God we
ask him alone you do not see a saying
that in the name of Muhammad peace be
upon him and Angel Gabriel and Allah no
you you guys do that you go to the I do
worships they do that the Hindus do that
many other religions do that we single
out God in his worship meaning we
acknowledge that he is the only one that
deserves our worship and we worship
alone yeah that's what we say yeah
you alone in worship and you alone we
ask for help and then when it comes to
his names and his attributes we do not
give we do not say that for example a
creation is the all-knowing it's the
all-powerful or give certain names and
weaknesses that the creation has to God
Almighty we don't come and say yeah God
Almighty for example the Christians say
he let go of his power and his knowledge
when they asked him about the hour he
became ignorant how could the oh no one
become ignorant so this is the
difference my brother Chase if you're
watching this because he seemed like you
know a man who's maybe I've never seen
you be hostile towards Islam you know
and I think I I admire that the fact
that you want to get about Christianity
but Islam is the one true religion and I
would say just because it's foreign to
you don't push it away get to know it
open embrace it and that's Nico said I
can't believe God is a man who came down
and died bro simple logic ABC
yeah I mean that's the thing I mean
there's an assumption here that there's
something that you'll that you're
bringing take towards one thing that's
already highlighted which is what has
Christianity got to offer in this uh
modern era like when it comes to LGBT
when it comes to feminism when it comes
to the family structure Christianity
doesn't really have much to offer I
would argue even when it comes to
theology it doesn't have much to offer
this is what we've been discussing
throughout the video as well so when you
say oh we're bringing him back to
Christianity what do you mean like tell
us what about Christianity are you
bringing him back to like what does it
have to offer yes exactly it doesn't
have anything to offer when it comes to
theology when it comes to practical real
life implications and already we're
running on a very low fuel tank so what
else could it possibly be and you ask a
small child in fact I would even say
forget the small child a small child can
tell you the illogical nature of the
Trinity and and the doctrine but which
Christianity which sect what's the safe
sector of Christianity what aspect of
Christian Catholicism protestantism here
Roman Catholic Anglican which which
Christianity now he can come and see the
same to us Shia this thought but the
difference is this bro in Islam most of
these sects that we have they all
acknowledge something Allah's Oneness
Quran final Revelation preserved the
prophet remember is the final messenger
these denominations that you mentioned
they all Becca bro they don't even know
what the Bible is they believe that
there's different Bibles like one Bible
has 70 books in it another Bible has 72
books all sorts of two extra books yeah
there's no sect that believes that okay
we've got this Quran and there's the
extended version of the Quran of course
my bro their Doctrine is all over the
place like they don't have something
concrete but that's it that's all I want
to say I hope you watch this video and
opens your mind look just read the Quran
man just give it a chance you've got
nothing to lose you know and Jesus is
not a white man with blue eyes by the
way if you have this perception that
he's on Western man he's not if you saw
him today you probably think he's a
Muslim that's all I have to say brother
and sisters inshallah thank you for
accompanying me on this thing come on
assalamu alaikum assalam